easy NBA it blocks over a two games
Bradley operating baseline for the easy
handoff and bucket simple give and go
right Howard
obviously this half also see at Moody's
coming off of a career times 44 points
there's that spin move
that's his signature move other guys can
actually play play because they get some
time that they wouldn't normally get to
them to respond on its way from deep
another three-point that's Terrance
Davis the second since tan is barely 200
we had their 11-point lead cut in half
and he scores and he's fouled goes to
the rim like that he doesn't always most
of the time he doesn't go in the same
direction he'll come back kuzmic thought
about going baseline cut off their back
[Applause]
[Music]
the three-time all-star event they
really ran everything through him I haka
we jack it once but he stays with it and
scores
close pass isn't open
is that pic point guard to talk about
anthony Galen's to steal he's going all
the way Drive begin matching it as a
Nancy Davis picks off an easy
interception there and then takes it
down and gets the assist to Quinn cook
88 points three assists 3 rebounds the
biggest one was to there without Kyle
Lowry and he leaves it for Anthony Davis
gave us all the way block that time by
siaka and Avery Bradley gets blocked by
Powell
that's del siaka target is where the
Lakers Mabry Bradley gets the assist
throws it up and Anthony Davis throws it
down he just carries it to the rim it's
got Jeff 6660 it's a fight tied against
the depleted champions see active turns
kind of occurs he's got an ad wall
the Raptors are back in his own mall
what up deep things by Vance wait and he
splashes it through Lakers just two out
of their last 13 ad that's a three got
it
give the assist to LBJ so Kyle Lowry no
Rondo again tonight for the Lakers we
thought we might see him five block by
ad and again he hurt his shoulder with
two minutes to go in the quarter Anthony
Davis straightaway knocks it down
that's Galanter our hallway splits the
defense here he goes all the way to lay
it up and in Seattle now the Lakers in
Anthony Davis there's that little
step-back that little wing step-back
that he is so adept at now Stu back and
forth
[Music]
who's gonna rise it fire over Kuzma for
three
seems like he's starting to get a green
one for his 17th well he finally made a
three Davis back for the Lakers
tied at 78 glad you're with us bounce
senator Coons hook blocked away by
siakam and Pascal comes up on the loose
ball who still want to see Atkinson gets
in that secondary defender and he get
Meg loss to this team nine still times
Boucher counted and he's gonna get an
add one it is a one way street
[Music]
[Applause]
the score makers need a run right here
Bradley another look at that law
hypnosis
Anthony Davis catches it with the left
guys at home at some play we're gonna
double up he's open
[Applause]
[Music]
cooked at 4.4 underneath Lakers got
lucky on his position now minute 20 left
lob to see Ottoman Toronto is in great
shape Lakers had their chances what's up
you guys this Taylor Brooks with
bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content